do you think consciousness is more than
a computation do you think the human
mind the way it thinks is more than a
computation
i i mean i i can say yes or no but but
but i don't think i have no reason
i mean
so you don't find it useful to have an
intuition in one way or the other like
when you think about algorithms do you
isn't it i think it's
the limits
unanswerable question in my opinion is
is no better than anybody else you think
it's unanswerable so you don't think
eventually science
angels can dance on the head i mean i
don't know
but angels
anyway there are lots of things that are
beyond that that we can speculate about
but
i don't want somebody to say oh yeah
canoe said this and and so he's he's
he's smart and so he so that must be
i mean
i say it's something that uh we'll never
know
interesting
okay that's a strong statement i i don't
i personally think it's something we
will know eventually like there's no
reason to me why the the workings of the
human mind are not within the reach of
science
that's absolutely possible and i'm not
denying it yeah
uh but right now you don't have a good
intuition i mean that's also possible
you know that
and ai you know created the universe you
know intelligent design
has all been done by an ai yes
this is i mean all these things are but
but but but you're asking me to
to pronounce on it and and i don't have
any expertise i i i i'm a teacher that
passes on knowledge but i don't
but i don't know
the fact that i
that i vote yes or no on
well you do have expertise as a human
not as a not as a teacher
or a scholar of computer science
i mean that's ultimately the realm of
where the discussion of human thought
yeah well i know we're unconscious
i know where where pendulus is coming
from he
i'm sure he has no pr
he might even thought he proved it but
no he doesn't he doesn't prove it he is
following intuition but
but i mean you have to ask john mccarthy
john mccarthy
i i think
uh we're totally unimpressed by these
statements
um so you don't think so even like the
touring paper on
uh on the touring tests
that
you know starts by asking can machines
think oh
um you don't think these kind of um
touring doesn't like that question yeah
i don't consider it important let's put
it that way
because it's in the category of things
that
it would it would be nice to know but i
think it's beyond knowledge and so i
don't
i'm not i'm more interested in knowing
about
the riemann hypothesis or something
so when you say it's an interesting
statement beyond knowledge
yeah i think what you mean
is it's not sufficiently well
it's not even known well enough to be
able to formalize it
in order to ask a clear question yeah
and so that's why it's beyond knowledge
but that doesn't mean it's not
eventually going to be formalized yeah
yeah maybe consciousness will be
understood some someday but uh the last
time i checked
uh
it it was still 200 years away
i haven't been specializing in this by
any means but but but i went to lectures
about it 20 years ago when i was
there was there was a symposium at the
american academy in in cambridge and it
started out by saying essentially
everything that's been written about
consciousness is
is hogwash
i tend to
tend to disagree with that a little bit
so well it's
so consciousness for the longest time
still
is in the realm of philosophy so it's
just conversations without any basis and
yeah understanding
still
i think
once you start creating artificial
intelligence systems that interact with
humans
and they have personality
they have identity you start flirting
with the question of consciousness not
from a philosophical perspective but
from an engineering perspective
and then starts becoming much more
like i feel like yeah yeah don't
misunderstand me i
i i i certainly don't disagree with that
at all um
and
even at these lectures that we had
you know 20 years ago there were
neurologists
pointing out that
that human beings had
actually decided to do something before
they were conscious of making that
decision yeah
i mean they could tell that
you know that signals were being sent to
their arms before they before their they
knew that they were
anything
you know les valiant has uh
an architecture for the brain and more
recently uh
uh
christus papa demetrio uh
in the academy
science proceedings a year ago
with with two other people but i know
chris does very well
uh and and he's got this uh
uh this model of uh
this architecture
by which you could uh create a
uh things that
that correlate well with uh uh with
experiments that are done on
consciousness uh
and and and and he
he actually you know has a a machine
language that in which you can
you can write
code and
and test hypotheses
uh
and so it it might you know we might
have a big breakthrough my personal
feeling is that
consciousness
the the best model
i
i've heard of uh to explain the the
miracle of consciousness
uh is
that that
that somehow
inside of our
brains
we're having a
a
continual survival for the fittest
competition
as i'm speaking to you uh all the
possible things i might be wanting to
say
are all in there
and there's like a voting going on yeah
right and
you know and one of them is is winning
and and that's affecting you know the
next sentence and so on yeah uh and uh
there was this book
machine intelligence or something
unintelligent on intelligence yeah bill
atkinson
was what was it was a total
devotee of that book well i like
whether it's consciousness or something
else i like the storytelling part that
we it feels like
uh for us
humans it feels like there's a concrete
it's almost like literary programming i
don't know what the programming going on
on the inside but i'm getting a nice
story here about
what happened and it feels like i'm in
control and i'm getting a nice clear
story so but it's also possible there's
a computation going on that's really
messy there's a bunch of different
competing ideas
and in the end it just kind of generates
a story for you to uh
a consistent story for you to believe
and that makes it all nice
you